Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David
P Here is a really important topic via
voicemail. The YouTube recommendation
algorithm. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, I long time. Western
just had a quick question for you.
Kind of a philosophical question
with the YouTube ad algorithm. It's incredibly
easy for big right wing audience or right wing
groups to buy up ad space and blast across and
take over political channels. So for example,
if I watch, you know, go to watch a clip of your
show had to go through a barrier of right wing
advertisements. If I go and watch certain atheist
channels, for example, I have to go through
religious ads before I can get to the content.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So there's two different things
going on here. There's two things going on here.
Number one, despite claims of left wing bias
on all of these platforms, Facebook and also
YouTube regularly recommend extreme right wing
and conspiracy content, even to people who only
are deliberately consuming left wing stuff. I
hear it all the time from my audience that's
number one, but number two, the right buys
ads on YouTube in a way that the left doesn't. And
I've talked about this before, and the right does
this in a lot of different areas. They are willing
to sort of have these lost leaders where they say,
even if we don't make money by spending money in
this way, we're going to do it to bring people
in, put people's attention in front of our
right wing content. And so even when you
watch left wing content, you often get ads for
right wing publishers. Why? Because the right
wing publishers are disproportionately buying
pre-roll ads on YouTube. And this is part of why
they often are doing so well in terms of
ground game because they're willing to
train up college grads. Right? We talk about
the think tanks and the other organizations
that they're willing to lose money, training
people and getting people into their orbit.
And YouTube ad spend is just another example of
that. I don't know what we can do to change it.
I don't know. We have a great bonus show for you
today. We'll talk about the new CDC guidelines
for quarantine and isolation under Omicron. We
will talk about a judge reconsidering a 110 year
sentence for a big truck accident that killed
four people. And we will also talk about
a controversial decision by Tesla, all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign up at
Join Packman icon and get instant access.
Unidentified: We'll see you that.